lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
aclarar las diferencias entre la
definición de la función interactiva
interactiva
y la definición de la función recursiva
de este lado voy a escribir recursiva y
lo haré realmente entendiendo cómo
funcionan las iteraciones en este código
y donde sucede la recursividad en el
código de la derecha
al empezar vemos que la variable
producto es igual a 1 y luego entramos
en el ciclo for que es la parte medular
de esta definición interactiva de la
función y para entender lo que pasa en
el ciclo ford déjenme hacer una pequeña
tabla pondremos el valor de la variable
i y también pondremos el valor de la
variable producto por y más 1 producto
por y más 1 porque en cada interacción
dentro del ciclo for evaluamos esta cosa
que tenemos aquí y luego voy a hacer una
columna para el nuevo valor de producto
producto déjenme subrayar esto aquí
tenemos el nuevo valor de producto
y aprendimos en vídeos anteriores que en
python decimos for y en range esta
función range de aquí nos devuelve una
lista nos regresa a una lista con el
número de elementos que nosotros le
dijimos con la variable número nosotros
le pasamos ese parámetro número así que
asumimos que este es el resultado de
llamar la función factorial de tres
factorial de 3
entonces el argumento que le pasamos a
la función factorial es 3i en la función
la variable número se va a referir a 3
entonces french de número nos va a
regresar una lista con los elementos 0 1
2 3 elementos empezando con 0 y el
último elemento es 3 menos uno o sea 2 y
en cada pasada de este ciclo ahí se le
va a asignar cada elemento sucesivo en
esta lista la primera vez en este ciclo
ford iba a ser igual a cero o iba a
apuntar a cero y luego producto por y
más uno para esta primera vez en el
ciclo producto estaba definido como
producto igual a 1 así que es uno por y
que es cero más uno y el nuevo valor de
producto es lo que tenemos aquí evaluado
producto es igual a todo esto y el nuevo
valor es uno por cero
que es uno por uno o sea uno y es todo
lo que tenemos en el ciclo por lo que
está intentado dentro del ciclo for y
debemos ir otra vez al principio del
ciclo fort o sea debemos hacer una nueva
iteración y la variable y ahora va a ser
igual a 1 esta expresión de aquí tomará
el valor de producto que sigue siendo
uno y tenemos aquí uno por uno más uno y
más uno es uno más uno o sea dos y el
resultado es uno por dos y el nuevo
valor de producto al final de la segunda
iteración es dos y ahora vamos al
principio del ciclo fort una vez más
otra interacción y tenemos que ir será
igual al siguiente elemento de la lista
y es igual a 2 luego producto es igual a
2 y tenemos y más 12 más 1 lo que es
igual a 2 por 3 que es igual a 6
producto es igual a 6
y luego al inicio del ciclo for
preguntamos podemos asignar otro
elemento a la variable y no ya no
podemos asignar ningún elemento ya no
hay elementos restantes en la lista y el
ciclo se rompe y salimos del ciclo for y
hacemos return producto regresamos el
valor del producto debo decir que
regresamos el valor al que la variable
producto hace referencia y el valor es 6
así que si llamamos al factorial de 3
nos regresará a 6 y si hacemos factorial
de 3 + factorial de 3 factorial de 3
factorial de 3 obtendremos esta función
evaluada esta expresión será evaluada
como 6 y esta otra expresión será
evaluada como 6 también porque es lo que
la función factorial devuelve y todo
esto será evaluado como 12 y esta es la
razón por la que llamamos interactiva a
esta función porque vamos
interactivamente a través de las mismas
instrucciones
y ahora vamos a comparar la función
recursiva que es un poco más divertida
una vez más haremos una llamada al
factorial de tres factorial de tres así
que 3 es el argumento es el valor al que
la variable número se va a referir y
entramos en la función 13 es menor o
igual a 0 no entonces no vamos a hacer
esta parte de aquí sino que vamos a ir a
la cláusula else y vamos a regresar
número por el factorial de esto que
tenemos aquí entonces esto se va a
evaluar como un número que es 3 es el
argumento que pasamos 3 por el factorial
de 3 por el factorial del número menos 1
y número menos 1 será evaluado como 23
menos uno es 2 y entonces tenemos 3 por
el factorial de 2 y esta es otra llamada
la función factorial así que regresamos
a la función pero en este caso el
argumento es 2 número es igual a 2 vamos
aquí sin número es menor o igual a 1
acepto pero número no es menor o igual a
1 es 2
entonces hacemos else y ahora lo que
vamos a regresar es el número x del
factorial de número menos 1 y en esta
situación el número es 2 y lo vamos a
multiplicar por el factorial de dos
menos 1 que es 12 por el factorial de 1
factorial de 1 y aquí haremos otra
llamada a la función entonces el
intérprete tiene que hacer algo así como
recordar que hemos hecho una serie de
llamadas a la función y tiene que
continuar avanzando más y más profundo
entonces hacemos otra llamada a la
función factorial de 11 es el argumento
número ahora se refiere al 1 y hacemos
sin número es menor o igual a 1 y si
ahora sin número es igual a 1 y esto es
el caso básico así que como número es
igual a 1 pasamos a esta parte richard 1
y en esta situación cuando llamamos al
factorial de 1 nos regresa 1
literalmente 1 y ahora sabemos que el
factorial de 2 es esta expresión
evaluada 2 por 1 o sea 2 el factorial de
dos es 2 y también sabemos que el
factorial de 3 es esta expresión
evaluada 3 por el factorial de 2 3 por 2
lo que es igual a 6 lo que es
6 así que tenemos diferentes maneras de
pensar para llegar al mismo resultado y
una vez más si tenemos factorial de 3 +
factorial de 3 no importa qué manera de
calcular usen el resultado será 6 + 6 o
sea 12